also leute sieht aus wie ein handy von
senioren würde ich mal sagen könnte auch
mein opa haben es geht wahrscheinlich
nicht an
doch es geht an alter leute der pass da
ist absolut kein bass drin war ich zeige
euch das mal kurz gedacht und herzlich
willkommen beim und video ja leute ich
hoffe ich geht es gut ich trete dieses
video frater um 12 uhr und wir fahren in
58 medium meldung gestellt also wir
fahren morgen früh in skiurlaub so um 6
uhr das heißt ich habe gleich fünf
stunden schlaf nicht mal ich hab das
aber irgendwie total vergessen dass ich
noch die möglichkeit habe das video
jetzt zu drehen dann kann ich es morgens
wenigstens ob ihr auto rad schneiden und
zwar folgende situation ich habe mir im
letzten wunsch video gesagt ja leider
ist das handy noch nicht angekommen
deswegen machen wir es heute so ich
zeige euch einfach die anderen sachen
die ich schon bekommen weil ich wollte
eigentlich als nächstes video dieses
handy video bringen weiß auch am meisten
gefragt ist einfach und weil ich es halt
selber wissen wollte und unter dem video
um viele geschrieben jo alex ist kann ja
sein dass das beim zoll liegt das handy
weswegen jetzt noch nicht da ist weil
eigentlich sollte es bis zum 24
ankommen aber normalerweise kommen die
sachen dann schon so drei vier tage eher
wenn nicht sogar noch eher und genau an
dem tag habe ich danach bekommen dass
das handy in köln liegt allerdings nicht
bei mir sondern beim zoll deswegen bin
ich noch schnell losgefahren das handy
holen war auf jeden fall jetzt nicht um
die ecke eine kurze aus und ich habe
glaube ich ein handy video gemacht so
leute
wir fahren jetzt gerade zum teil nach
köln weil ich habe mir nachricht
bekommen auf meine e-mail irgendwie dass
mein handy ein paar von euch haben das
auch schon kommentar geschrieben hab ich
gesehen und zwar dass das handy halt
vielleicht beim zoll legt wenn sich da
jetzt lange nichts getan hat und so war
es aber wohl alles was über 30 euro
fällt ich weiß es nicht genau
den genauen betrag irgendwie so dass
bleibt halt beim zoll also ich meinte
ich hoffe ich kriege das hängt jetzt
nicht auch weil sonst ich war wirklich
als 25 kilometer ja ich bin gespannt bis
gleich so und jetzt ist folgendes
passiert aber ich zeige euch das mal
kurs wir gehen mal kurz auf wunsch und
schaue was noch mal das handy an was ich
bestellt haben so ich bin jetzt genau
auf der seite dieses handy habe ich vor
ungefähr zwei drei wochen bestellt ich
weiß gar nicht mehr genau dass alkohol
rio 5.0 android-smartphone der lospreis
jazz today s kostet immer noch 1 30 euro
hat damals auch einen reich euro kostet
das gilt also vielleicht nicht nur für
heute das war toll die habe jetzt noch
nie gehört ich denke mal dass ein
rechtsfehler also eigentlich today ich
weiß genau ich habe das hier ausgewählt
zwei gewalt ram soweit ich weiß in gold
genau dieses handy habe ich bestellt
weil die man hier schon sehen kann
die handys sehen alle irgendwie anders
fotografiert aus man kann hier auch noch
mal was ändern also sondern wirklich
einheitlichen überblick haben wir hier
jetzt nicht so wenn man sich die
beschreibung anschaut
ein alko usb sinn und so weiter die
bewertungen sind auch alle gut für den
preis alles bestens ist super und
handlich und witzig denken hier welcher
mensch kauft sich dieses handy und
bewertet es danach und sagt auch für den
preis ist alles gut alles super und
endlich also ich bin ich der festen
überzeugung dass das für 1 30 euro nicht
sein kann und dass das dann nach zwei
wochen total abschmiert oder total
langsam wird war nicht schon sofort gut
jetzt muss ich aber sagen das handy ist
da und ich will es auch gar nicht
vorenthalten allerdings steht auf den
teil nicht älter sondern euskaltel oder
so also dass schon der erste fehler als
ich das handy dann zum ersten mal in der
hand hatte habe ich halt auch ausgepackt
um sicherzugehen dass es jetzt wirklich
das ist weil ich wollte nicht noch mal
dahin fahren so sieht es von hinten
und so sieht von vorn aus hotelkette
also um ehrlich zu sein wenn ich das
jetzt mal vergleich ich kann euch jemand
anderes foto anwender das originalfoto
so wirklich ähnlich sieht das jetzt
nicht aus dass hier oben ist gleich und
das hier unten überhaupt nicht
wahrscheinlich haben sie sich gedacht
ach wär schon und 30 euro für ein handy
bezahlt der wird auch nicht darauf
achten ob es jetzt wirklich das ist was
man bestellt
also wir haben ja einmal ein akku glaube
ich wirklich noch mal drauf hat alcatel
die marke habe ich auch noch nie gehört
genauso wie oreo aber ich jetzt schon
mal der akku hier ist der usb adapter
mit dem usb-kabel wir haben wir dann
denke ich mal kopfhörer
ja wir haben die kopfhörer ich hasse
diese fetten kopfhörer wir haben sogar
eine handy hülle dabei alter oder nee
nee das ist einfach die rückseite davon
alcatel pixie schnitt 5 megapixel kamera
das stimmt sogar
vielleicht haben die sich einfach
gedacht wir kommen wir schicken ein
handy was ähnliche leistung habe ich
weiß nicht ob ihr die marke alcatel
kennt alcatraz tja das ist ein gefängnis
aber wir nehmen einfach mal alcatel
alcatel war ein französischer hersteller
von systemen und geräten für die
telekommunikation rio vielleicht gehört
dazu oder so diese soll colin below
hingegen hat überhaupt kein
wikipedia-eintrag oder sonst irgendwas
also an dieser stelle muss ich sagen
total komisch schneider ich würde sagen
ich versuche das handy einfach mal zu
starten wir testen ist mal ob es
funktioniert ich gehe eigentlich davon
aus und auf mich wirkt das eigentlich
die den handy was man auch weil ich
nicht so viel 150 euro im laden kaufen
könnt also leute sieht aus wie ein und
handy von senioren würde ich mal sagen
könnte auch mein opa haben es geht
wahrscheinlich nicht an
doch es geht an ich finde einfach mal
ein bisschen mit meinem iphone also das
hochfahren geht jetzt nicht so schnell
übrigens man sieht mich da voll in der
spiegelung es geht ja so sieht das aus
die gar keiner jedoch wollte linien
nicht englisch wir nehmen deutsche ich
hoffe man kann deutsch leben ja wohl das
geht schon mal deutsch ja von der touch
ist miserabel ich connector des handy
mal kurz mit dem wlan kleinen moment so
läuft das hat schon mal geklappt anderes
gerät wenn sie ein anderes lager
nein danke melde dich an da habe ich
jetzt keine lust drauf also leute ich
richte das mal kurz ein melde ich mich
wieder so leicht werden es hier schon
mal hier finden sie ein auswahl der
beliebtesten anwendungen auf skype kann
man wohl installieren website kann man
installieren also wie man hier sehen
kann willkommen beim neuen start
programm
das funktioniert alles man kann auch gut
rüber vision der touch ist relativ
verzogen also das hängt ein bisschen ist
aber okay also das ist jetzt nicht so
wie mit der smart watch aus dem letzten
video das habe ich ja auch mal getestet
weil sie das noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut euch hier noch an
das war das letzte bild produkte video
testen also an das jetzt so gut ich bin
jetzt hier menü ich bin kein
technikexperte das ist ganz klar ich
kann da noch testen wie die kamera ist
ob youtube videos funktionieren wie sich
die musik anhört und so weiter und ich
würde sagen und facebook ist schon
installiert ich würde sagen die stadt
einfach mit der kamera ich habe ziemlich
gutes licht kann euch die fotos dann
auch hier neben einwänden also dieses
handy was ich jetzt auch wenn es
irgendwie ich vergesse die ganze zeit
dass es eigentlich gar nicht genau das
handy ist was ich bestellt aber man kann
natürlich sagen ich habe dafür 30 euro
ausgegeben das heißt ich jetzt davon aus
dass hatten wert von 30 euro
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal was dieses
handy für fotos machen kann
instagram ist auch schon installiert und
schaut euch das man jetzt einfach nur
das alte instagram logan sowie starten
die kamera und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt so schießt einer mal 111 ii
hier ich bin euch mal kurz die bilder
jetzt ein hier einmal dasselbe foto und
dann einmal das foto mit der normalen
camp das ist eigentlich finde ich gar
nicht mal so schlecht also ich kenne das
schlimmere handys wie gesagt immer im
hinterkopf behalten das ding hat und 30
euro kostet und dieses foto hat so gut
als nächstes testen wir mal youtube ich
will jetzt kein youtube runterladen
ich teste das einfach mal hier über den
browser so leute und wir sind auf der
youtube-seite und schauen jetzt einfach
mal nicht kranke baby elf millionen
klicks alles klar
danke das recht denn jetzt auch so leute
hier eintragen instagram mein leben
so sieht das ganze aus also ich muss
sagen funktioniert alles einwandfrei
man kann die kommentare lesen der sound
ist jetzt zwar nicht unbedingt gut aber
ist auch nicht schlecht alte leute
bereit immer im kopf das ding hat 30
euro gekostet weiß auch ganz genau als
ich mein erstes smartphone bekommen was
auch web site und youtube konnte das hat
130 euro gekostet und das war im
vergleich hierzu echt schlecht das war
langsamer der bildschirm war nicht so
groß die grafik war generell nicht so
cool wie hier und ich würde sagen als
letzten check könnten wir jetzt noch
einfach mal kurz in die musik reinhören
ich sehe gerade ich war übrigens in der
youtube app die war wohl schon
installiert hier youtube genau ich habe
am anfang gesagt der touch ist nicht
besonders cool er überzeugt mich aber
gerade irgendwie ich hab einfach mal ein
lied
[Musik]
alter leute der basta ist absolut kein
bass drin war ich zeige euch das mal
kurz über die kopfhörer basket grausam
aber das lässt sich natürlich auch mit
dem preis entschuldigen also es kann ja
nicht alles optimal funktionieren das
ding hat moment ich glaube sogar 16
gigabyte stand hier drauf und das
entspricht auf dem handy was hier
bayerisch war oder was ich eigentlich
bekommen sollte weil alkohol rio und
alcatel ist denke ich mal nicht das
gleiche ist für mich da ist gar nicht
beschweren ich hatte keine erwartungen
für 30 euro aber natürlich ist es
komisch dass wenn man sowas bestellt man
sowas bekommt ist ein gutes beispiel
dafür
es ist nicht das was auf dem foto ist
naja willkommen im internet ich würde
einfach mal sagen so ein gesamtpaket für
30 euro ist das echt eine akzeptable
leistung ich würde acht punkte geben von
zehn auch wenn das wahrscheinlich kein
interessieren mich auch keiner danach
gefragt hat jaja leute also wenn euer
handy kaputt ist und jetzt vielleicht
mal ein ersatzhandy braucht für 23
monate greift einfach hierzu ist okay
ich kann euch zwar nicht garantieren
dass das auch wirklich ankommt was ihr
bestellt aber ja es funktioniert und das
ist finde ich schon bemerkenswert für 30
euro ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lassen doch nach oben direkt auf jeden
fall instagram und snapshot wie schon
gesagt ich bin jetzt im urlaub ich
versuche natürlich trotzdem videos zu
drehen vielleicht von den einen oder
anderen block wenn ihr darauf bock habt
schreibt in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
haut rein